20% ou 25% du territoire
soit occupé par ces sources d'énergie.
Et je ne dis pas que c'est une mauvaise idée.
Il nous faut juste comprendre les chiffres.
Je ne suis pas du tout contre les énergies renouvelables. J'adore les énergies renouvelables.
Mais j'adore aussi l'arithmétique. (Rires)
Les panneaux solaires installés dans des déserts produisent
plus d'énergie par unité de surface, car il n'y a pas le problème
des nuages,
et cette installation produit donc 14 watts par mètre carré,
celle-ci 10 watts par mètre carré,
et celle-là en Espagne 5 watts par mètre carré.
En étant optimiste sur la concentration de l'énergie solaire,
je pense qu'il est tout-à-fait possible de produire 20 watts
par mètre carré. C'est plutôt pas mal.
Bien sûr, il n'y a pas de déserts en Grande-Bretagne.
Pas encore. (Rires)
Donc voici un résumé de ce que j'ai dit.
Toutes les énergies renouvelables, bien que je les adore, sont diffuses.
Elles produisent peu d'énergie par unité de surface,
et il nous faut accepter ce fait.
Cela signifie que si on veut utiliser les énergies renouvelables
pour faire vraiment la différence dans un pays comme
le Royaume-Uni à l'échelle de la consommation actuelle,
il faut imaginer des installations d'énergies renouvelables
à grande échelle, pas de la taille du pays
mais une partie du pays, une partie importante.
Il y a également d'autres sources d'énergie
qui n'impliquent pas les énergies fossiles.
Alors, il y a l'énergie atomique, et sur cette carte de
l'Ordnance Survey [service cartographique de l'État], on peut voir la centrale Sizewell B
dans un kilomètre carré en bleu.
Cela représente un gigawatt dans un kilomètre carré,
soit 1 000 watts par mètre carré.
Donc si on considère cette mesure en particulier, l'énergie nucléaire
ne nécessite pas autant d'espace que les énergies renouvelables.
Bien sûr, d'autres mesures sont importantes, et l'énergie nucléaire
a toutes sortes de problèmes de popularité.
Mais il en va de même pour les énergies renouvelables.
Voici une photo d'une réunion consultative battant son plein
dans la petite ville de Penicuik, non loin d'Edimbourg,
et on veut voir les enfants de Penicuik célébrer
la mise à feu de l'effigie d'une éolienne.
Les gens sont contre tout, il nous faut donc garder
toutes les options sur la table.
Que peut faire un pays comme le Royaume-Uni au niveau de l'offre ?
Eh bien, je dirais qu'il y a ces trois options :
les énergies renouvelables, sachant qu'elles requièrent
d'immenses superficies ; les énergies renouvelables des autres pays,
c'est-à-dire que nous pourrions poliment dire aux habitants
des pays en haut à gauche du diagramme :
"Euh, nous ne voulons pas d'énergies renouvelables dans notre jardin,
mais, heu..., est-ce qu'on pourrait les mettre dans le vôtre ?"
Et c'est une option sérieuse.
C'est un moyen pour la planète de gérer le problème.
Ainsi, des pays tels que l'Australie, la Russie, la Lybie, le Kazakhstan,
pourraient devenir nos meilleurs amis pour la production d'énergie renouvelable.
Et la troisième option, c'est l’énergie atomique.
Donc voilà quelques options au niveau de l'offre.
En complément des leviers sur lesquels nous pouvons nous appuyer au niveau de l'offre
et souvenez-vous, il faut beaucoup [d'énergie]
car actuellement,
90% de notre énergie provient des énergies fossiles.
Outre ces leviers, on pourrait parler d'autres moyens
de résoudre ce problème, c’est-à-dire en réduisant la demande,
ce qui implique une réduction de la population
— Je ne sais pas trop comment faire ça —
ou une réduction de la consommation par tête.
Alors voyons trois autres leviers importants
qui peuvent vraiment aider pour la consommation.
D'abord, les transports. Voici les principes de physique indiquant
comment réduire la consommation d'énergie des transports,
et les gens disent souvent, "Oh oui, la technologie peut tout résoudre.
On peut faire des véhicules cent fois plus efficaces."
Et c'est presque vrai. Je vais vous montrer.
Une voiture moyenne, comme celle-ci, consomme
80 kilowatt-heures pour cent personnes-kilomètres.
C'est la moyenne des voitures en Europe.
80 kilowatt-heures. Peut-on améliorer ceci de cent fois
en mettant en pratique les principes de physique que je viens d'énumérer ?
Oui. Et voilà la solution. Le vélo. Sa consommation d’énergie
est 80 fois plus faible et ça marche au biocarburant, le Weetabix.
(Rires)
On trouve d’autres options entre les deux, car
la femme dans sa voiture risque de dire « Non, non, non,
C'est un changement de style de vie. S'il vous plaît, ne changez pas mon style de vie.»
Bon alors, on pourrait la convaincre de prendre le train,
ce qui reste bien plus efficace que la voiture,
mais ça risque de changer son style de vie,
ou bien, il y a la voiture écologique, en haut à gauche.
Elle peut accueillir confortablement un adolescent,
c'est plus petit qu’un cône de signalisation,
et c'est presque aussi efficace qu’un vélo
tant qu'on roule à 25 kilomètre-heure.
Ou sinon, des options peut-être plus réalistes
dans ce levier, celui des transports, sont les véhicules électriques,
les vélos et les voitures électriques au centre,
environ quatre fois moins gourmands en énergie
que la voiture classique propulsée au pétrole.
Vient ensuite le levier du chauffage.
Le chauffage représente un tiers de notre consommation d’énergie en Grande-Bretagne,
l'essentiel pour le chauffage domestique
et autres bâtiments, en chauffant l'air ou l'eau.
Voici donc une saleté de maison anglaise typique.
C'est ma maison, avec la Ferrari garée devant.
Que peut-on y modifier ?
Eh bien, les lois physiques sont écrites là-haut,
décrivant comment la consommation d’énergie pour le chauffage
dépend de ce que l’on peut contrôler.
Vous pouvez contrôler la différence de température
entre l’intérieur et l’extérieur, et il y a cette
technologie remarquable qu'on appelle le thermostat.
Vous le prenez en mains, vous le tournez vers la gauche,
et la consommation d’énergie de votre maison va diminuer.
J’ai essayé, ça marche. Certaines personnes appellent ça un changement de style de vie.
Vous pouvez aussi faire isoler votre maison pour réduire les pertes
de chaleur : isolez les murs, isolez le toit,
changez la porte d’entrée, etc.
La triste vérité, c'est que vous allez faire des économies.
Ça n'est pas triste, c'est bien, mais la triste vérité c'est que
ça ne réduira que de 25% les pertes de votre maison,
si vous faîtes ça, ce qui est une bonne idée.
Si vous voulez vraiment vous rapprocher
des normes de construction suédoises avec cette saleté de maison,
il vous faudra installer des isolants extérieurs sur le bâtiment
comme sur cet immeuble londonien.
Vous pouvez aussi avoir un système de chauffage plus efficace en utilisant des pompes à chaleur
qui consomment moins d'énergie de haute qualité, comme l'électricité,
pour transférer la chaleur depuis votre jardin à votre maison.
La troisième option au niveau de la demande dont je voudrais parler,
le troisième moyen de réduire la consommation d’énergie,
c'est de lire vos compteurs.
On parle beaucoup de compteurs intelligents,
mais vous pouvez le faire vous-mêmes.
Utilisez vos yeux, soyez intelligents, lisez vos compteurs,
et ça changera votre vie comme ça a changé la mienne.
Voici un graphique que j'ai fait.
J'écrivais un livre sur les énergies renouvelables,
et un ami m’a demandé : «Quelle est la quantité d’énergie que tu utilises
chez toi ? » Et j’ai été gêné car je ne le savais pas.
Alors j'ai commencé à lire le compteur chaque semaine,
et les anciennes données de mon compteur sont représentées
dans la moitié supérieure du graphique, puis 2007
est représenté en vert en bas, c'est-à-dire au moment où
je me suis mis à lire le compteur chaque semaine, et cela a changé ma vie,
car j'ai commencé à faire des expériences et j'ai pu observer
ce qui faisait la différence, et ma consommation de gaz
a chuté car j'ai commencé à tripoter le thermostat et
le minuteur du système de chauffage,
ce qui a réduit ma facture de chauffage de plus de la moitié.
J'ai une histoire similaire pour ma consommation d'électricité,
en éteignant les lecteurs DVD, les chaînes hi-fi,
les périphériques de l'ordinateur qui étaient constamment allumés,
et en ne les allumant que lorsque j'en avais besoin,
j'ai également diminué d'un tiers ma facture d'électricité.
Il nous faut donc un projet avec plusieurs volets, et je vous ai décris
six grands leviers, et il nous faut agir massivement car
90% de notre énergie provient de énergies fossiles,
il va donc falloir pousser fort sur la plupart, voire sur tous ces leviers.
La plupart d'entre eux ne sont pas très populaires,
et s'il y a un levier que vous n'aimez pas,
n'oubliez pas que ça veut dire que vous devrez
faire encore plus d'efforts sur les autres leviers.
Je suis un ardent défenseur des conversations d'adultes
qui sont basées sur des chiffres et des faits, et je souhaiterais conclure
avec cette carte qui vous montre
l'espace nécessaire pour obtenir
seulement 16 ampoules par personne
à partir de quatre des grandes sources possibles.
Donc, si vous voulez 16 ampoules, souvenez-vous
que notre consommation totale d'énergie correspond actuellement à 125 ampoules.
Si vous en voulez 16 issues de l'énergie éolienne, cette carte montre la solution
pour le Royaume-Uni. Il faudrait 160 champs éoliens,
de 100 kilomètres carrés chacun,
soit 20 fois plus
que la quantité actuelle d'[énergie éolienne].
Avec l'énergie nucléaire, pour obtenir 16 ampoules par personne, il faudrait
2 gigawatts pour chaque point violet représenté sur la carte.
Soit 4 fois plus
que le niveau actuel d'énergie nucléaire.
Avec la biomasse, pour avoir 16 ampoules par personne il faudrait
une superficie équivalente à 3 fois et demie celle du Pays de Galles,
soit dans notre pays, soit dans un autre pays,
peut-être en Irlande, ou peut-être pas. (Rires)
Et une quatrième option au niveau de l'offre, concentrer l'énergie solaire
dans des déserts à l'étranger,
si vous voulez l'équivalent de 16 ampoules,
alors il nous faut ces huit hexagones
en bas à droite.
La superficie totale de ces hexagones correspond à
2 fois le Grand Londres dans le Sahara de quelqu'un d'autre,
et il faudrait que des lignes à haute tension traversent l'Espagne
et la France pour transporter l'énergie depuis le Sahara vers le Surrey.
Il nous faut un plan à plusieurs volets.
Il nous faut arrêter de crier et amorcer une discussion,
et si on peut avoir une discussion d'adultes,
créer un plan à plusieurs volets et le mettre en œuvre,
alors peut-être que cette révolution réduisant notre utilisation du carbone
sera sympa au bout du compte. Merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)